vous pensez ça que plus on est juif moi
on est français non je ne pense pas du
tout ça je pense d'ailleurs que les
parents par exemple était très pratique
en pratique est strictement la religion
et il était d'un patriotisme français
sont cieux donc je ne crois pas ça en
revanche je vous dis je pense que les
dirigeants de cette communauté ont pris
un virage communautariste depuis 40 ans
qui est mauvais moi je veux
revenir à la tradition assimilationniste
française c'est-à-dire
deux phrases simples de napoléon et
organisé vous savez comme vous savez le
journée du judaïsme officiel 1 vous
devez reparle des juifs évidemment vous
devez vous agrégé au peuple français
exactement ce que je fais je considère
que je fais partie du peuple français
car je me suis agrégée et 2 vous devez
considérer que jérusalem sépare c'est
exactement ce que je pense je pense que
nous devons revenir à ses fondamentaux
et c'est sur la base de ces fondamentaux
que je viens dire aux musulmans aux
français de confession musulmane
n'imitez pas les mauvais bergers qui
sont les dirigeants de la communauté
juive imiter plus tôt ce qui a été
l'histoire du judaïsme français de
l'isra élitisme et assimilés vous et je
vous dis exactement aux musulmans
français jeu de la phrase la fameuse
phrase vous la connaissez de
clermont-tonnerre rien aux juifs en tant
que nation tout en tant qu'individu
oui
[Musique]